hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar microfluidic based cell
sorting to better sample preparation for
10x
genomics applications i'm susie valdez
of labrutz and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by nano
select biomedical and 10x genomics
to learn more visit them at
nanoselect.com
and 10xgenomics.com
so let's get started i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of our presentation
also please notice you can share the
webinar on your personal social media
just click on that social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues
know about today's live event if you
have any trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation simply
click on that support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits tab
i'm sorry education credits please click
on the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
i now present today's speakers jose
marachi and dr brian spritz
jose moranches is the president and
co-founder of nanoselect biomedical
and dr brian fritz is the associate
director
of strategic market development and
programs in immunology
segment marketing at 10x genomics for a
complete biography of our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome gentlemen jose bryant you may
now begin
your presentation
hi everybody my name is jose maracha so
i'm very excited to be here and tell you
about uh sample prep upstream of 10x
genomics
and really show you how happy cells
means
better science so let me just go ahead
and get going here uh
what we're really interested i'm sure
why you guys are interested in being
here
is to really uh understand what each
individual cells uh want to tell us uh
and and allow us to uncover those things
because we strongly believe that
uh each one of these single cells want
to be heard
and understood they have secrets that
they want to tell us
and these secrets are very important to
be able to understand
from the individual single cell level
instead of
a from a population level and we
understand that these
by doing so uh it really allows us to
go into various different applications
whether it's single cell genomics gene
editing
antibody therapeutics cell therapy and
even into the plant world and even the
micro
world and luckily
in the last few years we've been able to
develop
many different tools that allow us to
really decode
and hear out and listen to
what each one of these cells has to say
so for this particular presentation
we'll be focusing on
10x genomics workflow um
that you know it's a great tool that
allows us to
probe each cell uh and look at various
things
uh a mix of things within each cell
and one of the things that is critical
when doing these types of workflows or
becomes quite critical
is the material that you actually start
with
at the beginning and that's the sample
prep
stage and we will be discussing on
uh telling you a little bit of some of
the things that can help
with uh being able to isolate and
prep your cell sample so that you have
the best experience possible and the
best results possible
uh when you're processing cells uh for
a workflow like 10x genomics which can
also be applied for
any other type of assay single cell
assay that you come across
and to be able to prep your sample
properly what's critical
is that you're able to isolate your
target cell population so that you're
actually doing the science and then and
the work on those cells that you
care about and in order to have really
good results you also want to make sure
you remove any background
material like debris or any dead cells
or any doublet so that you can
really be focusing on what you truly are
trying to understand
and remove biases in your science
and there are a number of things that
you need to really consider
and think about um and you sometimes
need to kind of take a step
back when you're designing your various
experiments
um and and think through of you know how
you're handling
and working with your sample uh and
here are just uh some very general tips
that sometimes get overlooked but uh
it's very important that
uh you generally use wide bore pipette
tips when working with cells again you
want to be very
gentle as gentle as possible avoiding
excessive vortexing gentle
centrifugation speeds
and obviously making sure that the
buffers that you're working with are
optimized
also maybe the temperatures as well so
those are very uh you know key things
very simple things that you should
always just
be considering and and be ready for uh
to have better
better results once you address those
things the next step is to enrich for
your target cells
uh while at the same time removing that
debris
any dead cells or any aggregates and
again all that
together is very important so that
you can get very good results uh with
your assay
um and if you don't do these things it
leads to various issues like the clog in
the gem
system degraded rna and in the end
obviously you're just uh
reducing the accuracy of your sequencing
results
and well you know everybody does you
know is
okay to agree that we don't want to be
spending um resources
on on non-optimal data or experiments
so i'm going to give a high level uh
overview of some of these
techniques that you can use to isolate
and prepare your sample uh the two most
common applications or technologies used
is magnetic beat cell sorting which you
guys are probably very familiar with
and then there's flow cytometry or more
specifically fluorescent activated cell
sorting
and these are two very common techniques
uh and
they have their advantages and
disadvantages magnetic bead enrichment
is
quite simple um although it's
uh you know it has quite a bit of
limitations of what it can do
high-speed fluorescent activated cell
sorters
obviously you can isolate and direct
cells into collection channels
using many different parameters at high
speed
and those are great but can sometimes be
very complicated to use
or an encumbrance for your for your
asset because you may have to go
use a core facility or may not have
access to that technology
so what i'll be talking about is being
able to use
uh technology that we developed called
the wolf cell sorter
which is an easy to use cell solder so
kind of takes
the advantages of having an easy to use
enrichment system like magnetic beads
but it also
it comes along with the multi-parameter
method of being able to isolate your
cells
and have those ready for downstream
analysis
and very briefly uh the wall of cell
sources give you some highlights of this
is something that you guys
we can forward you more information and
follow up on
but uh the advantages of the wolf sales
order
one that they when you sort the cells it
provides
samples with high viability you're able
to sort away your debt cells
but it's also not damaging the cells
because we use very low pressure
it's a very small footprint uh you know
it's the size of a
almost like a whole microwave you can
imagine that
um and then we use a microfluidic
technology which i'll talk about in a
second
that allows for the whole process to be
uh done in a stereo and disposable
system so that anything that the sample
touches
is part of the this disposable
cartridge so you have to worry about
cross-contamination
and most importantly what we really
pride ourselves with is that we develop
something that's very simple and
intuitive so you don't have to have
years of flow cytometry experience to be
able to use this technology to
very quickly and efficiently isolate
your cells and
and prep the sample before you begin
your experiments
and this is a provided at a fraction of
the price compared to traditional sales
orders
so what's behind this oh sorry and this
is uh
technology that's compatible with uh 10x
genomics
so our advantage here is that we use a
microfluidic disposable cartridge
and the sample is routed through these
these
channels and they get sorted just like a
traditional sorter we use
microfluidic sorry we use lasers and
optics to
identify uh the right cell you gate it
and then you can then sort that out the
difference is that we use this very
gentle piezo actuator
to gently divert the cells to the right
channel
and that's how we sort the cells and by
doing this process
our samp our cells are going through a
very low pressure
environment uh under two psi
and if you compare this to traditional
sales orders which can go up to 55 or 70
psi
so we believe because of this difference
we have
a higher viability especially with very
sensitive cells
and we'll show a few examples of that
in a little bit
so i'm just going to illustrate here the
importance of
doing uh cell sorting upstream of 10x
genomics uh
here just in an illustration uh you know
if you start with the population a mixed
population of cells
that may have you know you're uh you're
wrong uh
calling them wrong but it's your
non-targeted cells or damaged cells or
even you know dead cells and debris
and what you really want to isolate and
actually do your analysis
on are these live cells here in
open these blue circles
those are the cells that you really want
to isolate and move forward with
so if you were to start with that sample
and not do any
uh sample prep with cell sorting
upstream
um you can do that but you know it could
it will lead to issues
and perhaps fifty percent of your sample
may be useful
and therefore you're you know you're
spending more dollars per cell
whereas if you were to process that and
sort that upstream
well now you're taking advantage of that
and you're more of your
data bioinformatics and your cells are
actually going to be useful
and then in the end you're spending a
lot less money per cell
so this is a if you want to take away
the practicality of this that's why
we believe this is very important for
your experiments
and now i'm just going to go through a
few examples of that and so that you can
see for yourself and why this is
why this is important especially if you
haven't done or
not familiar with flow cytometry or cell
sorting
so this is an example with cho cells
chinese
hamster ovary cells on the left side you
can see
these are flow cytometry
populations that you can see before
sorting in the red
is a lot of dead cells and debris on the
bottom
we've labeled with propidium iodide
and in red or pi positive so they're pi
positive that means they're dead or
dying
and so you you wouldn't want to start
your experiment with this type of
population
so when you sort the cells afterwards we
get a much cleaner
population so uh pretty much only the
cells the
live viable cells that you then want to
analyze
moving forward so that's that's really
what you really want want to be
working with downstream so that
everything else kind of works properly
you're not getting clogged and you're
getting
very good results uh in the end
one of the most popular things that
people are studying and
and that's something that our next uh
presenter brian fritz will go through as
well
uh looking at t cells uh which is
obviously studying immunology
obviously studying uh you know within
now uh
in the covid world uh that also becomes
a major factor but it's also if you're
doing preclinical research with car t
cells obviously that becomes an
important
uh a type of cell to study
so here again uh we start in the top are
cells uh or the sample before being
sorted
uh this is starting with pbmcs and we're
targeting for
cd3 positive cells so you basically gate
for those cells
um on the top right there and then you
would also gate for only the live cells
so it's a multi-parameter gating here
i want live cells that express cd3
positive cells
and then you would sort that with the
wolf cell sorter
and basically you're left with mostly
all live
cells and only the ones expressing cd3
positive cells so you can see that we
get very good
viability and purity after the cell so
now you
have something that's more specific and
now you can look at
subsets of those of t cells in much much
more detail
using 10x genomics but now you start
with the t cells and you don't worry
about any other type of cells
and then this is just showing that these
cells are also not just pure and viable
but they're also
functional and what i'm very excited
about
and something that brian will go into a
little bit more detail
is what you can do with these cells with
these types of
single cell platforms downstream and one
of the new
applications is to be able to use
multi-parameter analysis with these
barcode technologies
and that's something that biolegend has
been developing
with their system and emudx as well with
their
system um and again that's something
that brian will go through but
it's an amazing technology that now you
can by by prepping yourself
properly and in this case say sorting
for cd plus positive cells
you can now go into much more detail and
look at you know dozens of different
markers using the the barcode technology
so what happens when you're looking at
very
low target population so let's just say
your target population is only
one percent of the total uh population
well there's tricks to be able to do
that very efficiently
and one of those is to do and use an
enrichment uh right before doing the
final cell sorting
so you could start with a pbmc
population from blood
you process that and in this uh example
we've used acadium beads
uh which are similar to magnetic beats
this is a different uh
way of doing that uh and these are ktm
beads can now
enrich for cd4 positive cells in this
example
uh to then eventually sort specifically
for regulatory t cells with the wolf
cell sorter and have very good viability
so by doing that uh we're able to go
after
rare populations of cells um and then so
here what i'm showing is basically pe
uh is pre-enrichment and then you do an
enrichment and then
post sorting meaning you can now sort
for only the viable cells very gently
uh and these are all pretty much all the
cells are alive
um and then we ran that with multiple
donors just to kind of show you an
example what you can do
going from like a one one percent or
lower
population target population and we can
consistently get
ninety percent or above um after sorting
uh um with respect to purity so again
now you can
take those samples and do any type of
10x genomic application or anything else
downstream
and this is a very simple
straightforward assay to quickly set up
and perform
okay now there's also going to be cases
where
you know it's it's actually quite
difficult to obtain
a single cell suspensions and that
becomes quite tricky and where we see
that a lot
sometimes it's when people are doing uh
neural research and they want to take
samples from brain
tissue or sometimes even from plants
where it's also very difficult sometimes
to be able to isolate and sort and
analyze those cells
so a common way of do addressing that is
to then
take take those cells and break them
apart
and and work with isolated nuclei
and i won't go into the details but
there are definitely numerous
a lot of literature out there showing
that you can
basically get a lot of insight and very
comparable insight
by analyzing and looking at nuclei and
they've compared that with
actual cells there's pros and cons
obviously but it is a very good method
or alternative to isolating and working
with intact
cells um so this is one way there's
protocols and different ways of being
able to isolate those specific for your
sales sample
so i would recommend looking at maybe
previously
publications there's information on our
website and
at 10x genomics website as well for for
those applications
so next i just want to show an example
of that so you can't take those nuclei
and then in this example we're looking
at
uh nuclei from plants uh
we're analyzing tomato uh nuclei and
green bell pepper
plants and this is an experiment that
was done uh actually recently so when uh
during cobit times which
it's a little bit more difficult to get
brain tissue as you could imagine
uh but it's much easier to work around
and play with uh plants
at the moment anyways uh as you can see
uh here we're basically just
looking uh with pi stained uh nuclei
and the top is the pre-sorted in the
bottom you can see
that the sample is cleaned up and part
of the main application here is to be
able to remove a lot of debris and clean
it up so that
you're you're actually sorting and then
analyzing only the nuclei and not
you know perhaps partially digested
nuclei or debris that's left from the
cells
and that becomes very important to get
richer cleaner data
okay now i'm going to go briefly on some
examples of
showcasing kind of the whole workflow
and comparing with
sorted and unsorted populations and then
going into a 10x genomics analysis
uh in this experiment it's a very very
simple experiment
uh we just try to uh look at the most
simplest way of analyzing this so we're
basically taking blood from
human blood and then doing a pbmc
analysis
and taking 10 000 cells each and
on the top we're basically going
straight into
uh 10x genomics um and then analyzing
that
and then on the bottom we're basically
going into the wolf cell sorter
and basically sorting for pbmc then
removing any dead cells and any debris
that's there
and then going into 10x genomics
experiment
and when we did that we saw very
promising results that when you look at
the median genes per cell
the percent reads not associated with
the cell
as well as the median umi counts per
cell
it's all improved when you sort the
cells
versus unsorted so it's not shocking but
i just want to clearly show you guys you
know the importance of that and how you
can get better better data
and then also when you look at the
populations uh
you also can see that there's more
clusters so it's kind of like
a higher definition of your of your
clustering um that you see
uh if you don't sort the cells we're
getting seven clusters
whereas if you sort the cells we're now
getting nine
different clusters from this pbmc
population
okay in this next experiment we looked
at um stem cells which are
um type of cell that's actually very
sensitive to sorting and manipulating
and working with
uh so we want to just kind of showcase
and and show that
uh with this experiment similar type of
experiment except obviously with ips
cells
um and then we're also comparing in this
experiment with traditional cell sorters
uh here's uh this is uh
done with the bd facts aria at a local
uh core facility here in san diego
and they set up uh this experiment with
uh this is their
traditional way of doing it for stem
cells where they try to be very gentle
with this technology as well using
100 micron nozzles and operating at 20
psi which is relatively
lower pressure for this for these
systems
and then uh analyzing that with 10x
genomics
as well so when we looked at that as you
can see
um unsorted versus sorted when you sort
the cells you're just getting better
data at least when you look at median
genes per cell
and the umi counts uh so whether you
sort with the wolf or
with whether you start with the facts
aria you're getting better quality data
and as you can see when you start with
the wolf the data looks even better
so that's uh i just want to maybe cap
the
experiments here that i'm showcasing
here with this paper that
uh we came across that was i think it's
an excellent paper
to analyze all the different conditions
that are required uh and or can affect
your downstream analysis this is done
from a group out of the university
restaurant
australia dr forrest lab and what they
did
it's a great paper where they basically
looked at different conditions whether
it's looking at 37 degree
or dissociation in the cold comparing
samples to nuclei isolation done at
various different conditions so it's a
great paper i recommend
you guys take a look at that and
basically the conclusion of this
obvious is that uh the results that
you're getting is very dependent on how
you optimize and what you did with the
sample so
it's very critical that you guys take
that into consideration
um when you're doing your experiments
so that's all i'm going to talk about
here i think this kind of
sets it up for brian to continue
his presentation and really go into
some of the techniques within 10x
genomics uh but i just want to wrap up
obviously that
when you're uh able to properly
prep your sample upstream and you sort
the cells right you go for the right
cells
you're now allowing these cells to open
up and
talk about anything that they want and
with these technologies now we're able
to see them and and understand them
um a lot better um so i'm trying to end
with a little bit of a lighter note
uh while you guys are sitting at home
you guys can share these uh
jokes wherever you want uh and if you
haven't figured out
the type of cell there that's a mr t
cell
um and i'll stop with the jokes i guess
but on a more serious side i do want to
thank uh
and showcase our our our team at
nanoselect a great group of scientists
field application scientists and
internal application scientists
and technical support and i really want
to call out nicole uh who
leaves a lot of the 10x genomics
applications
uh so uh we're not going to go directly
into q
a but i just want to at least put this
up there if you have any specific
questions
after this this webinar you can
email us info nanoselect
but i want to end there and i want to
now introduce
brian fritz who will be uh taking us
into
this new applications for sample prep
and 10x genomics
brian i'll let you uh take the take the
floor or the the web floor
thank you jose that was a great
introduction to the single cell
workflows that we'll be talking about a
bit more in detail in this part of the
presentation
i'd like to turn now from the background
that jose's delivered is thinking more
about the applications
that we can pursue with a single cell
approach to what we're calling
multi-ohmic cytometry
and we'll specifically look at some
immune profiling examples that so they
um alluded to in his part of the
presentation uh and
we'll hopefully leave you with some
thoughts to imagine how this can all be
implemented
in your laboratories as well
so of course we're all here because
we're interested in studying biology and
all of its amazing complexity and it's
useful to remember that
biology is an organism specifically
composed of diverse tissues and organs
those tissues and organs are themselves
composed of
organized and heterogeneous groups of
distinct cell types
and those cell types and cell states are
largely defined in
a number of different ways but gene
expression and protein function
particularly and so where we see genes
expressed and proteins expressed can
tell us a lot about the types of cells
that are present in a particular sample
so a comprehensive analysis of all of
these different cell types
really helps us understand first and
foremost how organisms are
comprised of these different tissues
organs and cell states and how things
can go wrong in disease states that
allow us to
understand the disease more effectively
we can think of studying biology at a
number of different levels and
one of the most important obviously is
studying at the level of the single cell
which are really the the basic sort of
quantum unit of gene expression
all of the gene expression that we're
aware of in human terms anyway
usually occurs within a cellular
environment so rna being
transcribed from from dna and translated
into proteins
in a single cell and then those two
analytes giving rise to some states that
we can then
measure with genomics approaches
but it's important also remember that
these two things use rnas and proteins
are not themselves static they're very
dynamic in in any group of cells you'll
find
that rna and protein half-life can be
very different the expression
patterns of a protein derived from an
rna and vice versa can be different from
one another
and there's a lot of really interesting
regulatory mechanisms in biology that
regulate the expression of these
molecules in single cells and so
having as many different analytes as
possible from a single cell is a really
interesting way of thinking about how to
understand biology more deeply
so i'll give you some examples of that
throughout this presentation
today and we'll focus again really
intently on the immune system which has
a lot of really interesting tools
developed for it a lot of interesting
publications to
reflect on how single cells and immune
states can be defined
we'll be able to think in about some of
these applications today we'll not be
able to get to all of them but
this is an example of many different
multiomic types of measurements that we
can make from a single cell
at the same time you can include
measurements of
rna and proteins as we've already said
we'll look specifically at layering in
some additional targeted gene expression
measurements of t
and d cell receptor genes as well as the
antigens to which those t and v cell
receptors are specific
we can also think about doing some
genetic engineering and introducing
crispr capstone
guide rnas that are compatible with
capture from the
10x genomic single cell system in the
future we won't cover this today but we
can also think about imagining
some applications where we're looking at
chromatin states as well as gene
expression at the same time
you saw some of this in jose's
presentation but we'll briefly go
through
just the quick highlights of how the 10x
genomics single cell
immune profiling systems work we're
looking here
at the many different parts of this
process that 10x genomics provides
and that's a system an instrument for
performing a microfluidic
separation of single cells in the
solution we
sell the consumables and other reagents
required to
[Music]
partition single cells and to perform
some types of genomic operations upon
them
and then we also support and sell
provide rather the software
required to take sequencing information
and turn into a biologically interesting
data set
within the heart of that instrument the
uh
workflow is schematically organized here
you can see our eight channel chip on
the lower left hand side
within that chip the microfluidics
channels collect
cells in an aqueous solution also
containing some of the enzymatic
reagents required for reverse
transcription which will happen
in just another step forward in this
particular schematic
and those cells and enzymes colliding in
solution with
a bar coded primer library which is
you'll see this in another couple of
slides that's physically
uh partitioned into single single
cells and partitions with a gel bead
called a
gem technology and what this allows us
to do is to introduce cells that
limiting dilution into that microfluidic
channel and capture them so there's a
single cell
per oil and water emulsions or
partitioned
within a larger oil and water separation
those partitions then within those
partitions the gel b dissolves
the cells are uh also lysed and so
we can start to capture the rna at a
single cell level
with the oligonucleotides that are
brought to that partition by the gem
itself that allows us to capture up to
80 000 cells
per plate per microfluidics chip
and we can do up to eight samples in
parallel through each of the eight
channels on the chip
we're expecting that we capture about
two-thirds of what we put in
for as long as the cells and suspension
are at the right limiting dilution
going into the system and uh
then again at the outset we can think
about designing experiments that are
compatible with whole transcriptome
targeted gene expression and as we'll
see a number of additional analytes as
well
you definitely saw this slide from jose
earlier but suffice to say again once we
start with
cells or nuclei as jose pointed out
in those input material for a gem
generation process within the instrument
we perform a bar coding of
cdna at a single cell level within each
of those
gel beads and emulsions and then break
those gems open
and perform the rest of the sequencing
library prep
on the bench in a bulk type of approach
which then allows us to put those on
in a sequencing instrument followed by
data processing
and visualization
so i mentioned that each of those
partitions that we capture single cell
and has a gel bead those gel beads are
coated with oligonucleotide in the
schematic
form of those javidaligonucleotides is
shown in one
form here so we can think about
combining
the capture of polyadenylated messenger
rnas with an oligodt
stretch shown here on the topmost
oligonucleotide in the gem
each of the gel bead oligos also has a
unique
molecular identifier and like its name
suggests this is a unique
um oligonucleotide sequence that we use
to count the number of transcripts that
we see in every single cell
and then assign those transcripts back
to a
single cell of origin using the 10x
barcode sequence which is
adjacent to the umi so these two
oligonucleotide sequences are critically
important parts of the gel v11
nucleotide technology
the gel bead oligonucleotide every
single 10x
barcode is the same so that all the
humans that associate with that cell
are then collapsed bioinformatically
back to the cell of origin with that 10x
barcode sequence
you'll notice also that there's two
additional capture sequences on the
skeleton nucleotide and this is from our
three prime gene expression platform
in this way we can design some very
specific oligonucleotide sequences that
we can capture
with these non-polydenylated sequence
elements since we have
a reverse complement structure on
oligonucleotide that we can
conjugate to another biomolecule like an
antibody reagent
we can capture that reagent within the
same single cell start same single
partition as the single cell that we're
analyzing
and shown here is just a representative
example of some of the types of reagents
that we
have been able to use within our system
that are brought to us by our commercial
partners
at biology and amudex and milicor sigma
respectively
we're able to think about employing
experimental designs with
antibodies that have been conjugated
with oligonucleotide bar codes
and we'll get into some experimental use
cases of these in the next couple of
slides after the introduction here
we've also been able to develop the
specificity testing using dexternal
reagents from immutex
these are peptide mhc molecules that
have again an oligonucleotide conjugated
to them so that we can count
the number of decimal reagents that are
inside of partitioning in the single
cell
and we can also think about introducing
guide rnas that have
an oligonucleotide bar code sequence
that can affect a genetic
modification to single cells and then we
can count the number of single cells
that have any
one of a number of highly multiplexed
guide rna molecules
so really the the first publication in
this entire space
uh shown here there's actually two that
were uh within
2017 um almost back to back in terms of
publication
the first of these was termed the seek
paper which was
a term given to this type of process by
the authors of that
publication really what they're
describing here though is the use of a
10x genomic system
to combine single cells with antibody
reagents which had canonically been used
for flow cytometry
the authors acquired the same antibody
specificities instead of attaching a
fluorophore to them a test
oligonucleotide
barcode sequence which was amenable to
analysis
in the 10x genomic single cell system
so in this way we're able to combine the
best of both worlds in terms of
cytometric analysis and next generation
sequencing
so the first use case described for this
type of multi-ohmic single cell approach
is shown here
and on the left-hand side we're seeing a
flow cytometric separation of t-cells
into two-dimensional space using
markers for cd4 and cd8 respectively and
we can see
the distribution of t cells that have
high or low c4 and cd8 expression
we see the same relative pattern of t
cells separating in two dimensions using
the multi-ohmic
cytometric approach which is again using
cd4 and t8 markers
to separate t-cells in a two-dimensional
space
but the real power of this type of
multi-gene expression and protein
epitope mapping experiment
is shown here in this experimental view
of the same
set of cells and on the left hand side
we're seeing a
tc or two dimensional image that's
separating the pbmcs
the starting material for this
experiment into their component cell
states based on
mrna based gene expression measurements
we'll see t cells separating from b
cells and k cells monocytes et cetera
and we're taking these
single cell colors for each of the gene
expression states and mapping them onto
the two-dimensional profile
of the antibody based measurement so we
have cd4 and cd8 separating t
cells into dimensional space again and
we can see that the intermediate and low
expressing
cells in this particular example map to
known
gene expression states that are defined
by the mrna based gene expression
measurement
so really with this approach what we're
able to do is take the best
possible use cases of cytometric
analysis and next generation sequencing
and put them together
to more finely resolve the types of
cells that are present in any particular
heterogeneous
system by looking at all the different
types of markers that can help us
resolve a single cell
one from the other
so we'll like extend this concept a
little bit further and look at a few
different other analytes that we can
measure in single cells
simultaneously and with this example
we'll start to look a bit more closely
at the the t cell receptors here as
shown in yellow on this particular spot
there's a really nice publication again
from new york genome center here
is an example of this that came out a
couple years ago
in in the same 10x genomic single cell
system
they developed a means for analyzing
gene expression at
mrna level where as well as paired full
length t cell receptor alpha and beta
and t cell receptor gamma and delta
genes
and they looked at 49 cell surface
epitopes for those barcode and antibody
reagents
at the same time as well as measuring
the
presence or absence of a large number of
multiplex
crispr calcine single guide rnas that
were introduced into the same system
that had an oligonucleotide barcode
sequence that was compatible with
capture on the 10x genomics
platform so in this particular
publication the authors demonstrated the
detection of a very large number of
different
bioanalytes simultaneously all from
single cells
were able to assess whether they could
have achieved a genetic engineering
of a number of different cell states all
in the same
heterogeneous sample
we can take this kind of concept and
extend it a little bit further and this
is work that was done
here at 10x genomics in the r d group
and
in this experiment which we'll go
through for the next couple slides of
the presentation
we're again thinking about sorting t
cells
using phosmetic analysis and then
incubating those t
cells with uh dextroma reagents in this
particular case
so that we can assess antigen
specificity of those t
cells as well as simultaneously the gene
expression
measurements of those t cells we can
assign a cell state by mrna
and self-surface epitope mapping
along the way we had to develop a lot of
uh experience with these types of
reagents and
and uh in combination with our
counterparts that some of our partner
organizations like biolegend
did a lot of work to qc these types of
reagents and make sure that they were
working as we expected that they would
and so we'll walk through some of those
qc steps first before we get into the
heart of the application itself
shown here is just one example of that
if we take the same antibody specificity
and this is
obviously done schematically in this
case on the one hand we'd have a
flow cytometry analysis using
fluorophore conjugated antibody
and on the other hand we'd have an
oligonucleotide conjugated antibody to
enable us to count
the same cell surface epitope and next
generation sequencing
experiment and we can use the secondary
antibody to verify the presence
of that in biology in terms of total
creation
which has the oligonucleotide bar code
associated with the antibody
so when we do this in practice the
results look rather like this so on
the um the top line we're looking at
cd14
bottom line cd15 and we're here
comparing
the results of analysis of these two
cell surface markers
with flow cytometry as in the far left
hand part of the plot
and with the total secret agents which
use next generation sequencing
as a detector and as an output you can
see if you have the
right amounts of antibodies titrated for
both of these two detectors you can get
highly concordant results and you can
look at
the results in terms of the total umis
as well as the amount of
antibodies standing by fluorescence
cytometry
if on the other hand you have an under
titrated amount
of antibody as in this particular case
for cd15 in an example
you start to lose some of the signal
that was otherwise present and when we
titrate the antibodies correctly
uh obviously this isn't the final
product that violation would be selling
but when
when you do this kind of work you can
more finely determine the
amount of reagent to use than any one of
these particular experiments
so here's another example of that shown
in a bit more detail
taking again this case cd3 and titrating
across
the range of concentration both with
feature barcoding or the oligonucleotide
tagging on the top line
and the photocytometric analysis on the
bottom line so
we can find that range of concentration
which you'll know might be different
between these two types of experimental
outputs
where the antibody reagents produce a
concordant result
and finally just another way of thinking
about how to visualize this data
on the left hand side here we're showing
antibodies
in approaching space and concentration
and
we show on the right hand side a
correlation with those
concentrations with the amount of
staining observed in the sequencing data
so when you have a really high
concentration antibody higher than
actually necessary you can start to get
a background staining which of course we
want to avoid so it's best to be able to
think about designing these experiments
with
the types of reagents that are available
from a commercial partner such as bio
legend in this case
who've done the work to make sure that
the energy antibodies you're using
are at the right concentration before
you use them if you're using something
that's
novel to you and it's just developed
from hybridoma for example then
these are the kinds of experimental qc
steps you might want to consider
before embarking on this type of
experiment
okay but when you have all these
reagents in place you have the
dextromers conjugated with
oligonucleotide
and fluorophore that allows them also to
be sorted you have
a combination of fluorescently labeled
antibodies as well as oligonucleotide
tag feature barcode enabled antibody
reagents
you can think about adding these all to
cells according to a particular
experimental design
in this case we load the dextromers
first waited 10 minutes
added the antibody reagents and then
washed a number of times before we
started to sort them for a combination
of
cda positive as well as dextromer
positive t
cells and so the gaining strategy is
shown on the lower right hand side
and from pbmc's the starting material we
went through a series of different steps
including a dead cell removal
as jose mentioned in his presentation
some of the resources for this are shown
in the upper right-hand side but most of
this is captured in some
demonstrated protocols that we have
available on the 10x genomics website
and at the end of the day we start off
with a number of
gems a number of single cells we've
reduced that down to a really highly
selected number of
cd8 positive and dexamera positive t
cells so as jose pointed out
float cytometry in this case is
absolutely critical to the efficient
success of this type of experiment we're
looking for really really rare
dexterity positive and antigen specific
t cells in a cd8 positive population
specifically
and so if we started from just bulk
pvmcs we'd spend an incredible amount of
money just sorting pvmcs before we found
these little needles in the haystack
so flow cytometry ends up being a
critical uh part of this entire workflow
that's just shown here in in a broad
view again we're taking
single cells and a bunch of different
reagents performing a full cytometric
analysis
prior to putting those sorted cells into
the 10x genomics instrument
after which we can capture
simultaneously from the same single cell
the gene expression
mrna based signature as well as a
protein cell surface
epitope mapping signature those feature
barcode enabled
antibody reagents and again the t-cell
receptor gene sequences specifically
as well as the antigen specificity of
those same t
cells all from the same single cells
and in practice what that looks like is
shown here so
when we uh have in this particular
example used a cmv picture a positive
donor
and sorted out tbmcs from that
particular donor
we're able to sort cells according to
gene expression measurements at the mrna
level
and we're also able to define uh cell
sorting states
using the cell surface markers based on
the total seek antibody panel that we
had available
at the time and in those same single
cells we're able to resolve
rather nicely some very specific t cell
populations that
are phenotypically distinct in some
cases yet have the same
uh antigen specificities so shown on the
right hand side for example we have two
separate groups some c and b positive t
cells both
specific for hla or hlb of 0702
and a very specific cnb peptide and
separately we have another entire
clonally expanded set of tcr clinotypes
that are specific for
hlao101 and other cuv specific
peptides so within the same experimental
design we're able to resolve the t
cell receptor gene sequence the tcr
specificity for antigen
in presence of mac molecule as well as
the self-surface phenotype
the immunophenotype of that same t cell
when we scale this up we've done this a
couple different times at 10x genomics
we can think about
inputting millions of inputs cda
positive t cells
we can highly multiplex the number of
different antigens that we
test for specificity for in this
particular case we have
50 total dextrometer molecules all the
eight of those are negative controls we
ultimately
derived about 200 000 single cells after
sorting
and it took us about a week of time um
for the rest of the single cell mouse to
get that
selected down to a group of about 62
000 antigen binding cells that we are
comfortable calling antigen binding
which results and collapsed into about
11 600
separate tcr clonal specificities for
antigen
and shown in the final bottom right
portion of this is what happens when you
add this single experimental data set
from a single cell genomics experiment
to the existing database of uh tcr
energy specificity interactions
so that ends up leading us with 43 out
of 44 of the engines that we tested
having uh defined t cell receptor energy
specificity
which 25 of those energies had never
previously had a tcr specific
test specificity described in a database
before
so those are novel entries into the vga
database that we're pretty excited about
following up
in more detail at some point in the
future
so finally in summary just want to
review where we've come from throughout
the presentation
had a bit of a review on nutanix
genomics technology and before that with
jose
a review on how to think about designing
experiments that incorporate soil
cytometry into single cell genomic
separations and workflows
hopefully giving you some insight into
how to use the combination of flow
cytometry with multi-omex cytometry to
design the right
best experiment to think about how to
identify those rare cells and
and to define heterogeneity and we can
also think as
they point out about applications in
stem cell research not just in
immunology
and hopefully give you some food for
thought about how to think about a
holistic workflow from
sample acquisition all the way through
to bioinformatic analysis and this type
of workflow
and i'd like to thank uh the rest of the
organization who's not
standing with me here at this
presentation but at 10x genomics the
broad group of people
in um r d sales marketing other roles
that helped to
provide everything that we had a chance
to talk about today and i'd like to
thank you for your time and attention
would be happy to take some questions
and thank you jose and brian for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just simply click on the ask a question
box located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look at our first
incoming questions
because our audience is already sent us
several
our first question is
for brian did you notice a discrepancy
between rna and protein detection
for any of the genes
yeah thanks for that question we do see
that pretty commonly
in our customers as well it's a very
common
molecular genomic phenotype of looking
at rna and proteins simultaneously in
single cells and
i think we have biology to think for
this and it's very cell type dependent
obviously so
where rnas are expressed sometimes
proteins are not
terribly abundant and where proteins can
be stably expressed rnas can be
rapidly degraded so really what this
enables us to do is learn more about the
regulatory mechanisms that guide gene
expression both at the rna and protein
level
and so we think that integrating these
kinds of observations into our
world view of the multi
state of single cells was really
informative as we learn more about the
data and we see this
applied to more and more cells and an
organism
thank you so much brian and our next
question is for you jose
can epithelial cells be sorted out
selected for enriched for from a mixed
cell population and actually this is a
two-part question
what are the minimum input requirements
for example
can disassociated cells from core needle
biopsies
be recovered with the wolf system
yeah that's a good question uh obviously
it is a little bit loaded and it
obviously depends always on
uh the sample that you start with uh but
you know what you really minimally need
is to be able to have
single cell suspension uh sometimes
there's uh reagents to allow you to do
that before putting that into
uh the wolf cell sorter uh and in the
end you know what you want to be able to
have
is a minimal number of target cells that
you're going after
and in our hands i mean it really varies
but we've been able to get away with
the very kind of low end in the 10 to 20
000 cell
range of target cells that you sort out
sometimes you want to sort a little bit
more just so that you
you have enough in case you have lost
during pipetting and things like that
i hope that answered that question uh it
was a little bit multi-part thank you so
much jose and
and actually continuing the discussion
about sorting
how long would it take to sort about 10
000 cells with a wolf's order or
a different way we asked how many cells
could you process in
like let's say an hour yeah that's a
great question
uh it depends on the concentration we
give a guidance of the
concentration of cells that one can
start with
and in about 40 minutes uh you can
process about a milliliter of sample
um and so you know from from start to
finish
if you're doing a whole a mil sample it
could be about you know about an hour or
so
from setup and the concentrations there
uh
again range from 100 000 cells per ml to
a million cells per ml
um and and that just depends on the uh
the purity that you want to get at the
end on the lower concentration of cells
you start to get much higher purity
and it just depends on how you optimize
your particular experiment
thank you very much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
we always love this live participation
brian how many genes would be detected
using the 10x single cell sequencing
yep a good question pretty common one as
well and and again this is a
cell type and sample type dependent
answer it's not all
metal cells express the same amounts of
uh
mrna but typically we think of being
able to capture many thousands of genes
per
cell from any sample and
you see a very large number of genes in
some sample types that express a large
number of rnas and some more primary
cell types that are
a bit more transcriptionally quiescent
we see many fewer but
it's generally in the range of thousands
thank you very much and jose how about
the cells how many would you need to
sort on the wolf for a 10x
genomics experiment
yeah like i said i think the um a little
bit similar to the
prior question uh i would say the uh
the minimal uh number of cells that
we've gotten away with i believe is in
the range of uh
10 000 to 20 000 cells uh but i think uh
you know
you would i would go by some of the
recommended um
requirements from the from 10x genomics
uh
which they sometimes would recommend
more just because you might lose some
cells
but i think because of our or the way
our platform operates
uh we're able to retain a lot of the
viable cells and not lose much cells
we're able to get away with a little bit
less
thank you so much and brian have you
have either of you looked
at the sample processing step using
tissue as a starting sample
we have yeah so there are a number of
protocols some of them are collected on
the 10x genomics website under our
support
dot sinex genomics.com resource pages
depending on which
product you're using and many others are
done by our customers so
in the publication record where we have
over a thousand publications now
um i'd say a large majority of those are
done with
tissue many different types of tissues
sometimes you get a better result with
nuclei as i'll say mentioned in his part
of the talk
just depends on the ease of which you
can dissociate
a tissue into viable healthy
intact single cells and protocol
dot io can be another resource that some
of the human cell atlas and other
customer types have been posting
resources and protocols too so
hopefully that answers your question
thanks
thank you so much and brian speaking
with you how many parameters
can i analyze in the 10x multi-omics
cytometry workflow
another good question so in addition to
all of the genes that you can detect
which we already discussed in another
prior answer
in thinking about parameterization and
more as a cytometric term
um the number of cell surface epitopes
that we have seen
assessed and this isn't published yet
but we definitely have people doing this
in practice out there in different
customer laboratories it's
well into the hundreds so um data sets
as large as 300 or more
are not inconceivable i think the choice
of how many of those parameters to
assess simultaneously is obviously
experimental design and sample
dependence so
what i think you can appreciate though
is that the number of parameters you can
look at is going to be
a mini fold higher than what you would
typically see with
a cytometric analysis using flow or math
cytometry technique
thank you so much brian and we have time
for a few more questions i want to
remind the audience that any questions
not answered today
will be answered via email
um brian actually one more for you did
you
have do you have any coded 19 related
data
generating using the 10x genomics
technology
that you can share uh yes we do we have
a coveted resource page on our website
which you can find through the product
areas and research areas for immunology
um we don't have any publications from
10 economics we do not have a bsl 2
cluster 3 facility so we don't handle
those kinds of samples ourselves
but we do have something like 15
publications now
um from customers and and probably three
or four times that many pre-print so
there's plenty of data out there to
choose from
if you're not finding exactly what
you're looking for on our resource page
or in publication
you can leave us a note at support
tennexonomics.com and we can help to
maybe find something else for you
thank you so much brian gentlemen thank
you very much for your presentation
today and clearly important research
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience
before we end today
if you'd like i'd like to say thanks
everybody for uh
coming and joining us uh today it's uh
great to have a very diverse
type of audience here and our team is
readily available to take additional
calls uh separately or you know have
one-on-one
uh video chats to kind of work through
specific uh
workflow solutions that you guys may
have
and same for myself thanks again for
your participation the devil is always
in the details here
and we have a lot of practice in our
customers as well and trying to turn
these applications into uh you know
publication ready types of
approaches so we'll get to the questions
that we didn't get to
offline and we'll be looking forward to
chatting more with you all
uh through email or other means in the
near future to answer additional
questions that you have
thank you again jose mouratis brian
fritz both of you for your time today
and for important research
i also want to thank labrut and our
sponsors
nanoselect biomedical and 10x genomics
for underwriting today's educational
webcasts
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
and questions we didn't have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe
take care bye-bye have a great day